matching cats
baby I feel like these are siblings dude
what
the welcome back to another episode of
careful boys today we got nectar heart
szer courtesy of under the
influence sir very delicious damn wait
which flavor are you having Anthony
leing Elixir what you wow I got the POG
one I got the Red Bull
they also do I I drank some and I didn't
get a headache so I took these beforeand
I did two I did two you guys are better
at promoting other people's products
than your own stuff I know right why are
we like this why we like we like our own
stuff yeah wait until you see Joe
promote our t-shirts though comes in
hard do you guys have a speaking of
pedophiles that's how Joe comes
in that's something that actually
happened earlier where we were like all
right we're going to promote this thing
and then somehow the video just became
all about pedophilia and we're like we
can't post this video now can't you're
one ad plug that video like like that's
it I just deleted maybe that's the
beauty maybe it's so bizarre that it
works like it I think so is that a thing
do you guys ever try stuff like that
make something so bizarre that it works
we've done that to like promote meat and
I feel like we'll do like a weird Trend
unrelated to what we're doing and then
like just because it's trendy at the
time it'll blow up and then just the
caption is like come party with us yeah
yeah yeah have you guys done anything as
bizarre as this put up your right
leg matching ta
[Applause]
baby all right all
right Brandon for that's fire I feel
like these are our siblings dude what
the [__] that's nice that feels good how
does it feel it's like a bizar alternate
reality good to to be Asian trash
royalty honestly great honestly great
cuz you know what comments we get all
we're not going to be invited to the
gala dude come on the G we never get
invited the issue I've had is literally
every time like Tik Tok does like oh
uplifting Asian creators I'm like I'm
never on that dude we never were either
ever if it weren't for our buddies at
Wang fu who always puts us in like they
had a [__] Asian entertainment
history book they put us in all this
stuff right so shout outs to Phil but um
we we never get invited to any of those
events because I feel like we're in
embarrassment that's how we feel yeah
but you know Bobby hundreds did a event
too that because he was like yo the
Cockroach Asians of you uh of
entertainment we never get invited so he
he did a whole thing he throws his own
we're not wholesome enough yeah we're
super really we keep it real yeah we're
super not wholesome but that's why we
[__] with you guys I feel like it's the
same Vibe and we get these comments all
the time where it's like they're
breaking every Asian stereotype there's
like let's like people can't think all
Asians are smart after this
one it's like the bad way yeah yeah yeah
it's like these are the Asian kids that
they don't let hang out like at church
or some [__] like it's always like what
what happened to these guys my favorite
is um when they say like yeah every
Asian parents worse nightmare you
know
but it's also true like Asian parents
would hate if if their son look turned
out to look like me it's still my mom's
worst nightmare it's still beef every
[__] day is it about the tattoos or
what no like she keeps bugging me with
[__] like [__] like so she's
getting her house like renovated
whatever and she keeps sending me like I
don't want to I don't give a [__] about
your shower door send me like 20 of
those pictures I'm like cool
bro that's really why that's the worst
nightmare cuz you know what his mom's
trying to show him his bathroom
renovation and he's like you abusive
[__] [__] you I think I'm traumatized
with my childhood but I think I think
she's trying to build a relationship
back with me he's like cool bro cool
bro yeah I think she's trying to build a
relationship and look at my new
sh but then you guys are generally you
guys got good relationships with your
parents yeah with my mom
yeah Mom Mom's always chill man
have my dad's the chillest stuff
really St D ask him why his dad's the
chill why why is your dad the chillest
he just hasn't breathed in a long time
oh man I had a feeling it was going to
go that way that's not funny that was
crazy not Nick give me a kiss dude only
if you don't make you feel my dad's also
very chill too oh you got chill dad he
doesn't say anything cuz he um he ran
away to
Korea we are alternate universe chill
parents in the house today dud you guys
have some cool D there's a lot of Bonnie
going
on a lot of trauma boxing that's so
crazy to hear because I always thought
like your guys' podcast like compared to
us like you guys are so nice and and
like nurturing to each other you guys
are very normal you talk about like real
like like mental issues and the dollar
store therapy concept all that [__]
we're just like toxic normal
we want to be like that but we're not
allowed because people these days are so
sensitive that's what I think it is I
always was curious if you felt like that
yeah honestly we're we're Millennials so
like we grew up on saying a lot of words
that we're not supposed to say now you
know what I mean you can say them all
right now too say it so I can trust you
on three whatever comes up say it first
what it comes to mind actually that's
actually my my whenever I meet someone
new that I think will stay in my life I
I tell them say a slur so I know I can
trust you yeah that was the right
opacity Gateway a Gateway word here I
think is
[__] that's a good one you guys bleep
that that's nothing too dude guaranteed
that won't be bleeped yeah really I you
know when I first came here and the
first time I started hearing them say
ret talk I was like that's crazy no you
said it first I did not say it I did not
hey off camera he'd be like we should
start saying it more and we like no
Anthony we shouldn't you were a clean
Channel you were a clean Channel he's
like I'm bringing it back no and
guy was randomly just dropping the other
F we were were CLE Channel and he kept
saying Osama for some reason yeah yeah
AMA Bin Laden
how how many times have you guys gotten
cancelled like four five I don't know we
been this is our 16th year so it's like
I mean the the odds are good the people
that try to cancel you they don't watch
you in the first place our fans are
been once in a while your [__] gets
popular goes viral and then like a new
audio audience gets it and then there's
a whole bunch of people with different
color hair coming at you yes and then or
something gets pulled out of context
it's always the colored hair know the
outside Watchers they don't know it's
almost like we're getting attacked by
[__] snow cones and binko and [__]
dude Shave Ice 4 five is not that bad
honestly I feel like we've been canceled
like four or five times really for what
the like one that stands out to me cuz I
was fearful for my life during this was
uh when we said beyond say hadn't had a
hit in the last 10 years Wasn't Me by
the way I didn't say it oh Jeremy said
that yeah Jeremy said that beehive came
after we're going to clip that right
there and we're going to repost it
Beyonce hadn't had a hit in the last 10
years that's different that's crazy
though you don't say stuff we don't even
say [__] like that it was crazy cuz
literally they were it was like going
super viral on Tik Tok hella duet
stitches and they were calling us like
KKK members it's like three Asian dudes
sitting and we're like we're talking
about like hits and in the same clip we
say yeah like Rihanna like as an example
of somebody who has had like recent like
Banger albums and then they're like
they're racist keep black women's name
out your mouth I'm like all we said was
Beyonce hadn't had a hit and and it's
not like we didn't say she was a legend
we just said in the last 10 years and it
was just like it was a crazy that is
Blasphemous though and you should
apologize we deleted it we apologized
you start calling us rward after the
show I'm going to call you Rihanna from
now on dude oh my God why we get a pass
is because when you look old and
irrelevant they don't care when you're
young and hip but when you're young and
hip yeah they go you should know better
going down cuz you guys are so like now
that I'm sure some people can't wait to
catch you doing something saying
something you know what I mean I will
say when I first blew up the the the
nature of how I blew up I had a lot of
liberals in my [__] and I'm I'm I'm the
type of person where it's like I know
what's right and wrong I always fight
for what's right I also believe in jokes
though so like yeah yeah I want to make
a drunk driving joke sometimes and
you're you trying to cancel me for that
I'm going to call you stupid yeah oh
yeah dude we were just making fun of
some guy that got mangled in a car
accident not too long ago we were
laughing so guaranteed nobody will bat
an ey also any anytime I do they do try
to cancel me i' fully just actively
fight back he double down you're in
there you're in the trenches like Trump
style yeah you stupid ugly [__] you
think I you think I give a [__] what you
say to me who are you to me yeah yeah he
started he's done like 18 video series
on one person like replying to every
comment that's how we were when uh we
made fot of Dolly Lama for like uh that
kid we did the same
thing all of the like Tibetans came
after us there's 20 people with the name
tenzen in our Tenzin dude when we talk
about the event we talk about the tenens
where it was literally like different
five different accounts making videos
they're all named tenen mad as [__] and
then we we're like listen we're sorry we
didn't really know that y'all be doing
that like that's what you guys said
basically like my bad keep that [__] to
yourself if you're like sucking on
tongues and [__] we kind of just doubl
down on it we're like n it's still not
cool a little weird you know what I
liked about um some of the con content I
remember now um it wasn't on your guys's
Channel but I think it was it was Viet
on Jimmy's Channel and then it's kind of
I think it's kind of similar how you
guys like talk about your issues and
stuff that's a little bit different from
the way we bury it and laugh about
everything and not ever be serious you
guys actually address certain traumas
and things you went through and I'm like
we do the same stuff but the difference
is I think like the way maybe we're kind
of the same generation but the way you
guys will Express it is there's more
like um knowledge now in Psychology and
just like things that are more better
terminology too right cuz like I think
we're like have you heard there's like
Millennial a millennial B right so
Millennial a is like us where we're
closer to Gen X and then there's
Millennial B that's closer to uh gen Z
and then the there's slight differences
in the two where like for us you know I
think we were called Gay for everything
or trying to say anything um that was
about feelings or whatever and then true
Millennial be is more comfortable with a
lot of those things and and talking
about it yeah I it literally is like you
said I think it's like um like we're
entering this age of like most emotional
awareness where like people have there's
like a lot of like literature that
dropped a lot of thought leaders that
talk about it and like as they talk
about it you realize like oh [__] like
it is emotional intelligence that brings
most people to like where they want to
go in life not IQ and I feel like
Millennial a up it's like it's like the
almost like the toxic like learn more
work harder shut up stop bitching which
at times is necessary but overall like
even you know research proves that the
most successful people are the more
emotionally intelligent ones also crying
is cool now
so I cry on that [__] all the time you
know it used to be embarrassing but now
I'm like damn that [__] is views every
time you guys start crying you guys
first time he cried our editor cut it
out and we yelled at him like why you
cut or he turned the camera off he goes
I didn't want you guys look like a [__]
yeah yeah yeah he's like are you sure
Millennial a right he's the editor of
millennial a that's why we keep the
lights on so like bright we look at it
and we're just like all right are you
ready are
ready you know do not you that what
[__] cry because of the cameras
really oh he would fake cry one of our
homies from Super Crew on on this dance
show we were on U he would be like he be
like all right got to get my tears on
because [__] TV way so good at it he
was so good crazy guy she's so good
though do you think it's it's it's
because like they feel more connected to
you or what is it cuz when I see someone
cry I turned the channel really makes me
uncomfortable even in the middle of like
a series you're watching that's why if
you cry right now everyone's going to
buy our merch dude Joe you got to cry a
little bit Hey try try to cry for real
that's just
coffee
cfee fear
everyone I don't even know why he's
crying coffee in his eyes coffee dude
that was coffee shirt he put coffee in
his eyes that was coffee coffee that's
just Brown as [__] that's hot coffee
that's Black Tears some dirty ass tears
dude June B March are so good it makes
you
cry cry brown
tears that was
insane was there what what were the I
know that like you took a a pretty
decent break recently oh yeah yeah but
the contributing factors I know you you
said you're working a lot and it was
like stuff was piling up what do you
mean a break you stopped posting um I
stop I like took a break from the
podcast for a bit so yeah I have like
three including the podcast I have three
businesses that I have to actively
run and manage basically and it's a lot
of work one and then like you have to
make content for for five channels right
so it's like and then what it was was
like there's like a whole team but then
like I'm like if I'm this busy and yet I
can make sure like I'm doing my [__] and
then I'll ask for like a very small
thing for from somebody and then they
just like show me that they don't care
it was like why am I doing this you know
what I mean like it's like it felt like
the all the pressure was coming in and
at times you're like I can handle the
pressure cuz it's like they need me but
at times if you're like you don't even
respect that I'm doing this [__] for you
then that's what like kind of made me
feel like I was collapsing and a lot of
it was my own brain I think like it was
like letting my this negative energy
that possessed me like kind of like
Fester but uh but yeah I defeated it and
it felt good to like take a break what
did you do on your break like what how
did you spend it oh it was [__] it was
mainly just like it was it was pretty it
was pretty dark I was like it was it was
a struggle for a bit like a couple weeks
it was just straight negativity like
straight no matter what I looked like I
could only no matter what I looked at I
could could only see the the the bad in
it like Kirkland peer life [__]
[__] or like or even like the loving
relationships in my life I'm looking at
them but I'm like only looking at when
they've hurt me rather than thinking of
like that's like cuz your own voice and
how you talk to yourself yeah yeah yeah
oh yeah this is filtered oh they poison
me but uh but no yeah exactly so it was
like and then I part of it part of me
realized that a lot of it was just me
and like it literally felt like I was
possessed like I didn't know how to and
then this book I was reading we actually
had the author on our show like taught
me a lot of like emotional tools like
how to like navigate emotions like that
and I do have like these like very
turbulent emotions like I was diagnosed
with bipolar when I was going to juvie I
kind of brush it off cuz like I lied in
a lot of ways to like get that diagnosis
but you feel like it was a real
diagnosis no I don't because when I look
up paranoid bipolar disorder I'm like I
don't do any of those things but it was
like I do have like these turbulent
emotions so that what are some of the
tools that you you were top so one of
them that I actually have been doing
unknowingly cuz I Journal is writing a
letter to the person like in in your
most heated like most like delusional
state of mind I wrote letters to all of
them and it was like vile like it was
like very angry so I wrote this letter
and like what it feels like is like
getting out your negative thoughts on
paper and then Rec consuming it through
another medium so while it's in your
head it's just thoughts but if you're
reading it it's like it's like words
right it's like you've created a new
medium to like consume your own thoughts
in
and then I woke up the next day read the
letter again and it was like even I was
like this is this is OD and I was like
if I was to talk to you guys in this
state of mind I would have probably
reflected her onto you rather than
realizing like taking the time to like
kind of like reread my own thoughts and
organize them better and then pinpoint
like why do I feel this way what's my
fault what's y'all's fault and like be
vulnerable and that's very emotionally
intelligent I think so you journal every
day not every day it'll be like months
in between and then I'll just like try
to like it's basically like I'm writing
my own story so that and it's cool like
what I've realized I like about it is
like I'll go back to like what I wrote 7
months ago and I'm looking at the
struggles I had 7 months ago that were
like top of mind they were like ruining
my life whatever right and I'm like oh
damn I I'll beat that [__] and like
where am I now compared to the S months
ago and I'm literally it's like telling
your future self it's like I don't even
know how to explain it's very cool to
read back good I'm just curious but what
were the top three things that you said
that were really mean on I was like's
old as [__] I was like she's never going
back Jeremy eats too much tahen yeah she
be eating too much tahen is wonderful
right on watermelon I have like a huge
bottle of T and I literally just like
just chug it so you guys don't know
anything that he wrote in those letters
have seen it did you burn it I mean I
did kind of I did kind of say it to them
in person like it wasn't it wasn't like
it wasn't anything that I didn't say but
it was just in the most like aggressive
way possible oh okay can I tell you
something as an unlicensed psychologist
I got a Bachelor's in thy uh uh you
don't got bipolar bro you if anything
hypomania and that's wonderful uh and it
just sounds like you just got ADHD like
and and When You're vulnerable you just
hyperfocus on the wrong [__] which is
negative [__] and then you know if you
channel that in good stuff like multiple
businesses or whatever we all got that
and and the [__] that you're talking
about it's like a hell guys got that
that are high performers that love to
get into 10 different projects but they
wi those 10 projects are all your
negative past things and things that
piss you off that's what happens yep
yeah he just diagnosed no I mean he's
exactly as an unlicensed psychologist
that got a bachor I was like damn that
sounded licensed to me
like hey I went to Cal State LA bro
Eagles baby you guys all go to college
or no yeah man yeah all of us did huh
wait you you went too you went took me
like eight years a guy like you guy with
a face like that wait what does it mean
by guy like you cuz he thinks I'm the
no I thought he dedicated his life to
fighting cuz he was professional
fighting no I wasn't I don't I don't
think any of us are using our degrees
except for him really yeah that's true
what was your degree in I got mine in
kinesiology ah so I never even useless
meet head degree yeah honestly we all we
all dropped I was a film major and I'm
on camera right now hey what's up
brother do you use anything you learned
in the film major well the only problem
is technology advance is so quick it's
like all useless everything that we were
using is like dinosaur [__] now that fo
learned on a camera like this and [__]
like I was a horse major and now they
got cars so Horse Major it was so old a
horse
M where are they offering that you went
to University UCI you graduated no I
have one more semester oh you didn't
graduate I dropped out for [__] dance
yeah oh for ABDC right cuz you always
bring up U something oh he graduated for
sure no I didn't I I had literally one
actually one quarter you think would you
ever finished no it's useless I was in
uh literary journalism but you're a very
good writer though were your parents mad
when you when you dropped out oh dude
yeah I broke their heart they're still
mad I had to finesse my mom I was like
I'm taking some time off to make money
to go back to race are you Filipino
Indian we should we should have made you
guess I know what were you thinking I
don't know I couldn't tell top three
guesses what were your top three oh yeah
he looks like a Pakistani biker
yeah he's like a Bollywood [__]
henchman yeah Bollywood henchman is yeah
that's wild dude I ever since I have a
beard then people think I'm I was
looking at you I saw the beard I'm like
as just don't grow beards yeah there's
like a small small set of Filipinos at
for some reason Japanese people too they
have colonization hit just right I've
been growing this for 3
years
dude D getting new news careful boys is
a brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kiding news the number one podcast
in the
[Music]
world